so the Civil Rights protection against
discrimination on the basis of religion
doesn't just mean that you can't just
you cannot discriminate against employee
for their religion it also means that
you as the employer cannot force an
employee to bow down to your religion so
the question is whether the modern Dei
agenda or wokeness or whatever fits the
Supreme Court's test for what counts as
a religion turns out it meets that test
in Spades certain clothes you can't wear
words you can't say apologies you must
recite it's a systematic worldview
rather than a world view on a narrow set
of questions secular humanism meets the
Supreme Court's test work out
sacramental exactly so wokeness you know
certainly meets that test to a T and so
actually much of what you see in
Corporate America even in the schools
Etc the enforcement of the Dei agenda is
actually a civil rights violation not
under a change law under existing law
today so I'll I'll instruct the
Department of Justice to prioritize
ridding ourselves of this National
Cancer by applying would have ever
thought are civil rights laws evenly